it almost seems as if there's a school
of thought that some people should fill
out a financial aid application before
launching that Go button on a
Kickstarter IndieGoGo site and I'm just
paraphrasing but how do we know someone
really has X amount of dollars in the
bank do you think that should be part of
the prerequisite for launching a
campaign is to go through almost like a
college financial aid application well
what are you what do you have in
reserves what's your monthly income
things like that or is it also about
generating a fan base I generating a fan
base there's a perfect question I've
never solved the generating a fan base
question I've I I tried to generate a
fan base when I was trying to be a
singer songwriter for under electronic
music answer I tried these sort of
things and I find it a I found it very
hard to do I found the key thing for me
was um was generating the the
performance and showing opportunities
and of sufficiently interesting projects
so the whole fan base thing for me I a
lot more people hear about my work than
see it because at the heart of my work
is these unusual ideas and what will
often happen is the ideas get propagated
widely and I get interviewed about the
ideas but then the project is kind of
shown in a performance venue at Plymouth
University in the southwest of England
or you know or in a cinema at Plymouth
that we do obviously we have performs in
San Francisco so they do get around so
my my fan base is kind of if it could be
called such a thing has been brought
about by emailing by tweeting there's
been a lot of it and also just people
reading about what I've done and
contacting me it's something I've not
really thought about I've just noticed
people taking interest in what you're
doing in some ways I I try not to think
about it they might sound awful but I
don't need to think about it as much
because of the fact that I have these
these ideas based projects
ideas get widely you know didn't cost
anything to distribute an idea no it
doesn't cost anything to release an idea
it's a it's very easy and then new
opportunities come up to do the next
thing so I don't think about I don't
need a hundred thousand people each
paying three dollars each or five
dollars each to finance my next project
or to enable me to move on to my next
project so I don't tend to think that
that way so as far as it goes with the
crowdfunding site I I have do you think
that would be fair to keep the quote one
percent of filmmakers if you want to
call them that and we don't even know if
that's really true but the perception of
them being in a higher income bracket
probably it is true but to keep them
away from crowdfunding sites because
they don't need it they don't need the
money I can't see this being an ongoing
problem like i mean III it seems to me
that isn't it reverse discrimination in
substance yeah it it just seems it just
does it's the sort of problem i can't
see you're going to get a whole load of
like famous film makers continuously
using crowdfunding websites it's it's
like if I was if I was in a position
where I was well known enough that I
could if I used a crowdfunding website
it was news that Alexis Kirk could use
the crowdfunding website I would use a
crowdfunding website but I'd use it once
because the second time what what does
it give me I mean it gives me money I
suppose but a my mind tuitions telling
me the crowdfunding the whole heart of
crowdfunding is based around people who
have not i hate to use this word haven't
made
it that's awful phrase I don't know what
else I think that you people understand
what I mean when I say that yeah and
it's for its so you've got the people
the sellers who haven't made it if you
like so they need to raise this money
and then you've got the buyers who want
to be part of a project now let's face
it no one's expecting to be able to be
part of the next Steven Spielberg movie
you know I'm not expecting to be able to
email Steven Spielberg and say um listen
I good luck his his hundred dollars for
your next movie and you know then to
have his third ad be in contact with me
regularly telling me what's going on you
know there's no one's expecting that
that participation I think that with
crowdfunding websites you also get this
sense and it happened we work with
myspace when myspace was going you'd get
musical artists on myspace people felt
these and these were music artists who
were relatively new one of the most
powerful elements of myspace a quite
powerful item to myspace was that you
could have contacts with these music
artists whose music you loved and you
you know that they weren't famous as
such they hadn't um they hadn't made it
as such but they were but they were
great artists you know and they had some
of that glamour of someone who's made it
they were in the business they were
there's something glamorous about people
that throw themselves out there you know
there's something glamorous about
somebody that will take a huge risk and
make a feature you know it doesn't
matter whether there's even spill
cordova there's someone that will do
that Saunders in the film business
because they've taken that risk you know
and they're working with a crew
something glamorous about somebody and
they're putting themselves out there
with a script with direction whatever
somebody who will make her who will
record a song a write a song they'll
record it they'll pay the money to go
into the students do it properly they'll
make a real effort you know and they're
clearly they're putting themselves out
to look stupid bye-bye by doing this you
know they're taking the risk not only of
time and money but of looking stupid
because I think so many people we fear
that if we try and look like a
successful artist we're going to look
stupid I think so many people feel that
and there's something glamorous about
the people look
that risk not just about the people that
gained national enquirer or whatever you
know is that and crowdfunding is an
opportunity for the general public to
interact with people taking this
glamorous risk if you like and I think
that's an element with it as well I
certainly know and I've been on the
other side of the crowdfunding thing
it's been quite tempting to think you
know wow be part of this movie and the
guy's not famous or anything but maybe
it'll be a successful moving i'll have
been part of it or you know so i think
that's quite a strong element but the
fan base thing is not really my my
element as much
you